That's like saying you're a tourist who's
never been to the United States, and you're
coming for the first time.
What can you learn?
Well, there's all kinds of things you can
learn.
You can go to New York.
You can go to a national park.
You can go to a mountain.
And then, if you get a chance to come back
briefly two years later, you'd want to come
back again.
Well, it's the same thing for the solar corona.
It's a part of the sun — and billions of
trillions of other of other stars — and
we can see it only at an eclipse.
Each time we look at it, it's different because
the sun is different.
It varies with the sun-spot cycle.
There are eruptions that go off, and things
change all the time.
So since we only get a few minutes every couple
of years, we look at its motions.
We look at its image.
We look at its spectrum.
We look a thousand different things as much
as we can in the brief period that we're allowed at an eclipse.